hey guys Rob here day one of gamescom
2015 and I'm joined by Danny seventh
hello who's been to c104
not a bad way to start your day a bad
way to start right now
turn what you've got low say about it
right yes so I turned up a Bethesda's
booth we got to see a 25-minute excusive
extended Gamescom special gameplay demo
which was narrated by mr. Todd Howard
himself Oh
so I basically Wednesday with my phone
and date of mind the entire thing so I'm
just gonna like tell you almost
chronologically what happened okay okay
first up they show you another first
they showed off basically what they
called the perk shark so when you start
the game you pick your special stuff
strength perception endurance all that
sort of stuff for you to give you like
10 or so and you feed them into the
different categories right yes you've
done that you can basically then unlock
each each app each letter each like tree
has its own set of unlockables in that
so upgrade within it right well if you
put like say 10 into strength right off
the bat for whatever reason you've got
unlock the 10th one immediately you
could unlock 1 2 3 4 5 6 or the 10th
endurance or strength what your comedian
so basically they're encouraging you
right off the fact that you're not only
just getting the the stats you're also
getting whatever extra perks those are
upgradable so there is 70 perks in total
and then their ranks so there's 275
different ones so the bloody mess and
yeah being able to like trick people
with your with your with your voice
which are words like I'm doing that come
to Gamescom it's great yeah is which was
which was really cool so it shows you
that like there's there's a lot of like
extra depth in terms of that right off
the bat there's like an almost
encouragement to instead of just like
picking a couple of perks like 2 or 3
like you did in the other game so if
you'll be able to do a bit more depth
there and one other thing about that
which is interesting is that in the
strength thing there like things you
need strength for like incumbrance first
of all like carrying items that's
important you know building things and
whatnot and then you'll carry too many
things that can weigh you down he's I
slowed down a little bit right
one of the things they mentioned which
hasn't been in the Fallout game as they
showed a guy swinging at a small bat and
ball boy like hitting a but hitting a
ball so I think that maybe there's a
level a mission in diamond city where
you actually have to swing and hit a
ball and your strength determines how
far you so if you're a baseball player
if you're if you're Red Sox fan you what
I go to Fenway in the game make sure you
strength is high before you do it you
will see one of them talk about the
environment as well right yeah so like
what a massive open world game right yes
and you know like one of the things came
out of the initial reveal of the game
was of like oh it's the ball that again
the animations are a little bit janky
and all that I really like how this game
looks so a bunch of feral ghouls poured
out of a building and generally this is
like oh they they'll just they'll be
standing idling and then I see you and
one towards you like little touches
they're all like poured out of windows
that I climbed in or Windows right down
one thing I will say is that the
shooting with those animations it's so
much better so obviously we're all used
to like using vats slowing down the game
that had a lot of sort of barriers for
gameplay with the last game in this one
you can like use loose these fats and
like it doesn't pause time it slows it
down a bit but what it also does what to
sort of improve shooting and I see to do
is there's not so much of a reliance on
fat and when these girls were coming
towards the player and this in this demo
there was a lot of sort of extra play
with what to do so we was like shooting
off arms we're like shooting off legs
and then two more flags there on the
ground and then they were like shot off
- are they cooling off
oh yeah they shot harms off them and he
was just like you know come jump Awards
in my case well you could be really sue
this thing with that yeah so it was
thought that was super fun yeah you had
your dog there as well you go ask him to
do commands like you know stay or like
look around he growls right before the
girls turned up right so the last bit on
the baseline gameplay I mean so we had
to rely on bats in bullet ways for like
big open battles is that the same case a
or just improve of it yeah there was one
big problem with the last what all the
games and was most noticeable in new
Vegas in the final levels which was sort
of is supposed to be the big faster
battle on the Hoover Dam
was that the follow games have never
been good with massive amounts of
enemies because that's was so you're so
reliant on vats and you couldn't really
shoot from the hip accurately so one of
the things they showed in this was the
sort of plastic half-life 3 wave battle
where it's you against a bunch of
Raiders but there are also ghouls
involved right they had a bunch of yeah
right so they had like a lot of writers
up on the top that grows like climbs
coming for you coming for them
yeah then they dropped in some
Brotherhood of Steel guys right so it's
like a four-way fight now oh well you're
wait the Brotherhood it goes are going
for them the vertibird is also firing
from up top and they're like shooting
the vertibird and then this big behemoth
turns up there's massive mutants so then
it's like in previous games you can
fallout games you couldn't do that
because you basically end up using vats
sitting back trying to get your vats to
go up again and it almost turned into
this kind of sort of weird board game
where you were like reserving vats and
then going up shooting it in this one
shooting dudes vertebras blown up ghouls
are attacking these people like Snipes
to deal with the fat man runs right in
the back and get your fat man shoots the
fat man down on those guys behemoths
like it was just like all right okay
this is like what they've been trying to
make for ever in Fallout and they've
actually managed to do this so if that's
emergent gameplay if that's happening
dynamically then that's gonna be a
absolute fence that's thick it might
just be a set piece but who knows right
I know it is very much fun like it was a
set piece I think in terms of like maybe
that the backup came in but they've said
you can call him back up on the game so
I'm sure right like even if it is like
regardless there are a couple of those
in your Fallout games like these
instances did happen so the ability that
now you can get involved in massive
firefight and not spend your whole time
standing behind a rock and shooting over
the top like a reality so tell me more
about the open-world and in terms of the
loading screens and how it easiest to
get round so it seemed like it was like
no loading screens walk
they did do a fade out fade in when you
went to the building so I think perhaps
that's still a thing yeah hopefully
small loading screens but it didn't they
didn't show you walking into buildings
and lots of like familiar things
actually the lockpick minigame was the
same the terminal hacking minigame was
the same so they've advised slots but
they're still like sort of little touch
stones they're little and changes to the
interface though have sort of cropped up
here and there there's no radio menu for
weapons and for items which I imagine
our things that you can choose so
instead of having to dump back to your
pip-boy all the time right up from like
a compact shot okay into a missile
launcher and you can just go flick flick
you can do the same without putting in
and stimpaks presumably taking right
away the treaty helps and another thing
was that like bodies on the ground
usually just go up and you hit a
Toulouse now if you mess over them it
tells you what's already there so you
can just take all okay but it lets you
know also as you dream loading it yeah
yeah you also he can let the dog do it
so you can ask the dog he like asked him
to lose somebody and like the voice came
in he said check if there's anything
good there so maybe the dog when he gets
you weapons or stuff like that right I'm
hey I'm your Walker and doing a lot of
big stuff he's like saying I got I see
if a hawk there so not only is the
voices come out the the narrator's
talking protagonist I think when you're
in conversations but also like walking
around the game world he's doing this
sort of like Nolan North kind of like
just like saying stuff that's happening
when you're walking around which
actually works pretty good
and another little thing I saw was the
rightness like super granular now like
rads instead of it being a like a
detriment to your health that's like
taking it away and actually takes some
of your health bar so there's like a red
line that your health can't go past if
you're if you've got a radiation
sickness also the crit thing was really
cool you've got this basically a I'm not
sure when it triggers is it like based
on your scale or based on your weapon
but there is a crit button where you can
like win it win at highlights and in
vats you can just go for a crit
go for a critical attack and one of the
things I saw them doing the video was
the dude was going around just like a
ripper or a baseball bat or something
and this raider comes up and it comes up
crit and he like animation like kick
some nuts balls on the ground I just
baseball bat like boom
right which is cool so like because not
only is there like all the like normal
you're just shooting people in their
heads are just going turning it to mulch
but they also had sound like ooh a
little deaf animations in there as well
so apparently this game is like 400
hours big basically you can spend 400
hours playing this game recording to the
pizza well I'm getting that's true from
what you've seen but I start 20 minutes
so I can say that it's at least 20
minutes long confirm my partly because
dealing with it all I saw was the
Lexington area obviously this game is
really big what I will say is that as
somebody who's a big fan of series who
recognizes that there were some very
fundamental problems for it in terms of
definitely the shooting and definitely
it's like the scale of battles it was
trying to always mimic but never really
making yeah it was it was almost like
watching when you're watching a theater
when you're watching a play I'm just
like five people there and it's this
massive dramatic thing that's happening
that's supposed to signify like a like a
loads more people there and they're
fudging it and you sort of believe it
because you want to believe it Paulette
was always like that where you're like
yeah I'm trying to believe there's this
massive Hoover Dam you know partl but I
never felt like it you're falling for it
felt like a big barn raising and that's
really exciting
well thank you so much spending all the
latest on fallout 4 13 Facebook
you